oh that's sex pistols one of the
all-time great anarchic bands you can
listen to that all day fortunately we've
got one of the men behind it
johnny rotten john lydon the great man
here here live peace unleash great to
see you
we're going to be doing a regular catch
up with you called johnny's rotten world
because the last time he came on it
popped so well on youtube everyone was
watching this they love your unvarnished
uncensored view of life well i like to
tell it as he is yeah you know i'm not
influenced by the media yeah yeah but
they are very seriously influenced by me
yes
you just can't you're rehearsing with
your new bad pill today in london yeah
i'm straight out of rehearsal so forgive
me if i look a bit sweaty and moist
the girlies apparently like it that way
did i ask you about politics for a
moment because you said something quite
interesting the last few days you talked
about how it used to be the right that
was seen to be the completely intolerant
fascists who never allowed people to
have different opinions and so on and
now it's gone full circle oh it's
absolutely the left swings the
roundabouts now in it i can't trust
anything coming out of labour anymore i
i i began to despise them really yeah
it's too they this woke agenda and all
of this nonsense i can't be tolerating
that you know i i'd rather vote
conservative because at least i i can
rely on their hypocrisy but i don't want
to vote for lunacy
it's plain and simple when you see the
debate over boris johnson and these
parties
really at the core of it it's just that
they were all partying in downing street
when they were telling everybody else
you can't go and see your dying
relatives
that white man speak with fork tongue
you know
do you think he's a liar boris oh
completely
so you know if you're going to write
these laws in and insist on them and
then deliberately go and break them
yourself well that's that kind of
hypocrisy is is just a little unfeasible
for me and sodium you know he's like all
politicians really a professional liar
but by god that bloke bone you had on
there defending him wow what a piece of
work
he reminded me of that old tory kind of
creature that i used to really really
hate and loathe so
you know get rid of both of them and
things might be on the look up but on
top of that
i would like a prime minister that is
capable of partying but then don't be
introducing laws that you're not going
to follow yourself and expect the rest
of us to oblige right it's the hypocrisy
is the problem right it's wicked wicked
i wish i was at that party though
i think you're living it up
[Laughter]
what do you mean we're in obviously
jubilee week and god said the queen was
this iconic anthem at the time it was
all about anarchy and so on you've
you've softened a little bit over the
years is that right you say about the
queen in particular no no this is the
media again trying to uh take the
destination out of the the h bomb i
dropped on that song uh i am as uh
as uh solid about monarchy and my uh
dislike of it as i ever have been to me
i've always viewed the royal family as a
bunch of german and tourists with a
greek thrown in
you know uh but as a human being right
she ain't no human being as representing
his state she doesn't represent me i
don't want to pay no more tax to keep
that institution alive but i totally
respect her as a real person that she's
endured that and maintained yes a sense
of dignity and i'm always attracted to
pageantry and this is you know i grew up
loving the arsenal and if we weren't
waving our flags that's as close to
pageantry as you can get there's also
something i just think we look at the
way politics has gone around the world
really it's so
so much corruption so much hypocrisy so
much you know really incredible
characters getting to run countries yeah
and you think at least in the queen's
case you've got this woman who's barely
put her foot wrong she's dignified she's
humble and so she's controlling all of
that yeah you know what i mean it's like
it's almost if you just view her as a
sort of calming figurehead for the
country she's been one of the most
impressive people that we've ever had i
would say
but god bless if she kicks the bucket
what's gonna follow well that is a
genuine problem i mean tonight we have
the archbishop of canterbury saying that
for example we should not be looking to
forgive
people like prince andrew that he's
shown that he wants to make amends for
what he did but my issue with that first
of all find him guilty before you
forgive right
and the archbishop of canterbury i mean
i'm sorry but that has the ring of child
molester about it
you mean in terms of the way that the
church the church all of these
institutions and of course they all
cover themselves up but as i say first
find him guilty of something it's
obvious he's hiding something
i don't trust him and when you have a
when you have the queen's son
who pays millions of dollars yeah to a
woman who was accusing him
of having
in america underage sex with her and
being involved in sex trafficking with a
paedophile yep when he does that having
said i'm going to fight this and clear
my name even though
he didn't even though there was no guilt
attached to this settlement the fact
he's had to pay millions of dollars what
does it say a settlement is telling you
everything
uh it's almost like a bribe to go away
isn't it
now the poor lady in question i mean uh
she knew what they'd like uh they'd rip
her apart in court as basically you know
so take this cash under under hand
it's victimization again and if that if
that's going on in the future royal
family i don't want none of them can you
forgive somebody in this circumstance if
they don't accept
what they did when we don't even know
what he actually did because he won't
you won't say can you offer forgiveness
if people don't show any atonement for
what they may have done
no it is a holier than thou about it uh
i just won't be tolerating there's
something there
just
bring it out wash your dirty laundry in
public and let us be the judge of that
right not under the underhand deals
going on
this is the continual world they're
introducing us into isn't it complete
corruption
well i'd like to see a brave new world i
i do think it's caused uncalculable
damage to the royals because i think
that we've never had a situation where
the senior royal has been involved in a
settlement like this and it's not like
it was a you know sort of financially i
think we have seen royals in the past
histories have definitely involved in
all better i think in modern times is
what i would say and it's a serious
matter you know jeffrey epstein was a
disgusting billionaire
running up no not at all i mean my real
issue with it is that andrew carried on
seeing that guy after he admitted and
was convicted of pedophile behavior yeah
there's all manner of money laundering
possibilities lurking in the background
right too like why did he carry on being
his friend you know because
this is my taxpayer money it's right
that's being spent right now
bugger off right no but i think i think
it's a legitimate reaction that most
people have to it what what do you think
about the jubilee celebrations are you
going to get involved you're going to be
in a street party are we going to see
the man who sang god save the queen
singing it with love and affection
why not
i love the party side of it right yeah
and that's and the pageantry and
everything pageantry and the flag waving
and being part of a wonderful bloody
country
they've got no shame not plenty of pride
about britain and i'll wave the flag any
way i like safety pins included do we
talk down the country too much i think
so i do
uh
that lady's done no personal harm to me
the institution has and and it's
obviously riddled with corruption
you know
i i just pity what comes after her it
just i've got no hope for it i think we
should uh really uh
start voting on a new queen
really yeah let's have an election who
would you fancy meghan markle oh someone
from australia
i want to ask you about something else
top gun so i got very excited yesterday
about talking i went to scene top i
loved the new movie i loved the first
one and to me it restored
masculinity and being a man yeah do you
see anything in this well i'll tell you
there's a shortage of modern war movies
right and uh you do need those kind of
characters really if your country is
going to survive any threats of invasion
you need proper blokes to sort it out
and try to sweep that under the carpet
with this new era of woke is
unacceptable to me
we need men's men i'm sorry but that's
just the way it is and this is idea that
masculinity itself is wrong oh toxic
it's all toxic yeah i'll have a vodka
and toxic masculinity please
it does annoy me because of course there
are some men who are toxic but there are
also many men who can show masculine
qualities which actually not only are
good qualities but women like men to be
masculine because that's human nature
right right and and to go against nature
really shows like a major flaw and a
weakness in the idiocy that's coming
from extreme left politics i i i find it
very very alarming that young students
are so quick to jump on this like a name
slurry business without really thinking
the thing through but also i think now
the students but they're all dressed as
men and women themselves yeah but
they're arguing against but this idea
that a minister can go there who's only
said that he believes a woman is an
adult female and for that he has to be
hounded with abuse
because you actually have labour mps now
women mps saying actually women can have
penises
well of course they can that's how you
get babies
but
i sort of feel the world's gone mad a
bit if you're working against nature
because of some new political and
dangled theory then you're a bit of a
fool and i'm afraid the young are very
very foolish in this and i must say not
all young just those who've gone through
the university systems they seem to uh
not be educated anymore but really
institutionalized i want to play we do a
little segment called worlds most of
them should be in an
institute we do a regular thing called
world's gone nuts i think you're gonna
like this story john because this is
actually something normally at the end
of the show i'm gonna play it play it
now watch this
now this is a a love story that might
not take off
it involves 22 year old sarah rhoda who
lives in dortmund germany and she's
announced that she's in love with a
boeing 737 passenger jet and has plans
to wed said to jets the future mrs 737
identifies as an objective sexual
meaning she's attracted to inanimate
objects and has
50 replicas of the flying love machine
unsurprisingly it's not legal to
actually marry a replica aircraft in
germany but neither the law nor common
sense to stop other people from doing
things like this in 2007 erica labrie
married the eiffel tower changing her
last name to eiffel and kate cunningham
has been happily married to a tree for
nearly three years but true love never
does run smoothie poor akihiko condo who
married a hologram character has been
has been left devastated after the
expiration of the software meant he
could no longer talk to his father
john
when you look at stuff like this i in a
way it's a kind of wonderful thing that
there are people this mad out there
right i think so i find that
entertaining but the the shocking one
really for me was the girl fondling the
747 bottle i mean that's one up on a
battery operated penis
[Laughter]
and god bless her if that if that's what
turns her on it rings her bell you know
john i can talk to you all night
fortunately we've only got to wait two
weeks till you're back on it's been
brilliant to have you on please
you are as unsensitive as it gets i
thank god for somebody who just speaks
their mind and doesn't care what all you
cancelled culture wokey say because you
can't cancel a sex pistol right you
certainly can't and i'm on tour with
public image limited to prove it y'all
come on down now
shut your mouth
[Laughter]
yes sir
everybody the winner john brown
my man breasts we will have john
johnny's rotten world every two weeks
from now on because i cannot interview
this guy enough this is what we want in
life plain talking straight talking
uncensored it's so easy to just tell the
truth isn't it it is and yet it's not
easy for a lot of people and i thank god
people like you are doing it and i'll do
it too and hopefully we'll put the world
to right good to see you john my last
thing on boris rules are for fools and
he's proved the point by breaking his
own
i think that would be perfectly sums it
up